New York Times reporting student loan
forgiveness program approval letters may
be invalid the Education Department says
more than five hundred and fifty
thousand people have signed up for a
federal program that promises to repay
their remaining student loans after they
worked ten years in a public service job
but now some of those workers are left
to wonder if the government will hold up
its end of the bargain or leave them
stuck with thousands of dollars and debt
that they thought would be eliminated in
a legal filing submitted last week the
Education Department suggested that
borrowers could not rely on the
program's administrator to say
accurately whether they qualify for debt
forgiveness well then who the flip can
if the people you idiots at the federal
government hired the idiots you idiots
hired cannot say who qualifies then who
the flip can unbelievable only the
federal government could be this
incompetent
on with the article the thousands of
approval letters that have been sent out
by the administrator here's the other
idiots federal loan servicing which if
you've ever talked to those people you
know what I'm talking about their
parents or cousins the thousands of
approval letters that have been sent out
by the administrator fed Loan Servicing
are not are not binding and can be
rescinded at any time the Education
Department said the filing adds to
questions and concerns about the program
just as the first potential
beneficiaries reach the end of their
ten-year commitment so after 10 years
we're gonna look at you and go what just
kidding
after you did yeah you believe you
believe the federal government yeah
that's what the clock started ticking on
the remainder their debts for borrowers
in the American Bar Association filed
suit
in the United States District Court in
Washington against the Department of
Education the plaintiffs held that jobs
that they were initially told qualified
for debt forgiveness only later have
that decision reversed with no evident
way to appeal they say the suit seeks to
have their eligibility for the
forgiveness program really restored
there is so much wrong with this I don't
have time to cover it problem number one
don't be so stupid as to wait ten years
to pay off your student loan get six
jobs sell so much stuff the kids think
their next live on beans and rice and
get rid of your student loans that's
problem number one never sign up for
something that keeps you in debt for 10
freaking years that is an indication
that you need to make more money and
that means you need to do more work and
get this mess cleaned up 10 years is not
acceptable time to stay in that period
that's just stupid on your part don't do
that I get calls every week should I do
the ten you know you should not do the
10 year forgiveness program no I've been
saying it for 10 years no don't do that
the other problem is I mean what kind of
ethics Oh Ethel and federal government I
just almost said that the same sentence
that was done uh is there that I mean
Congress if you guys don't put your
little hands together up there and sing
Kumbaya and pass a law to smack your
Education Department in the mouth and
say the very agency that you hired the
administrator that you hired you have to
stand behind what they said that's just
basic integrity unbelievable Congress I
can't believe this even makes the New
York Times and Congress hadn't already
got a bill on the floor I mean in 30
seconds that ought to be a I mean this
is something Democrats and Republicans
ought to be able to agree on that the
federal government shouldn't lie to
somebody for 10 freaking years and then
go oh just kidding
you still owe the money gotcha you get
to start again welcome to the student
loan lottery yeah if the
traitor hired by the federal government
says you're out of the disputing loan
debt after 10 years you should be out it
was a stupid plan to begin with you
shouldn't been in the stupid plan to
begin with already covered that but if
you were stupid enough to get in the
stupid plan to begin with the idiots at
the federal government there's a lot of
stupid in this whole thing right here
they should be made to abide by the
ruling that their administrator it's a
law it's the law of agency it probably
technically doesn't apply here for you
lawyers but basically when you are
someone to represent you guess what they
represent you and what they say is
binding upon you and that's the concept
here it's a basic ethics concept it's a
basic legal ethics concept you don't
have to be a lawyer to grasp this one
yeah so the administrator hired by the
federal government says that you qualify
but the federal government comes back
and goes no not so fast we don't think
we like them we hired them we paid them
we gave them the power to completely
administrate everything having to do
with your loan but except for that part
when they said you weren't gonna owe any
more after 10 years of working for this
particular public service job and we
were just kidding see this is the kind
of crap you deal with you don't think
the borrower slave to the lender when
you hear something like this you do
understand the borrower is slave to the
lender see when you're a slave people
just make up crap do whatever they want
to they just move stuff around happened
to me when I was going broke I couldn't
believe this - these bankers man I just
made up stuff they just lie I mean this
is the federal government looking at
five hundred and fifty thousand people
and going we lied you're screwed we lied
you're screwed
how Congress has not fixed this in 30
seconds Democrats and Republicans really
ought to be able to agree on this one
pretty quick this is not like a problem
that really I mean basically the federal
government ought to keep its word
that's not hard you know really you
ought to maintain your integrity but
here for the rest of you don't get the
stupid plan and then you wouldn't have
the problem so
you know there's enough crazy and stupid
to go around in this hold of story here
so the Education Department says that
federal loan servicing its administrator
does not have the binding the ability to
issue a binding agreement on their
behalf
what a crock Wow unbelievable well kudos
the American Bar Association for
reaching over and punch them in the
mouth at least somebody's looking up and
standing up for this Congress it's time
I don't get in your politics you guys
all fight up there about nothing half
the time don't do much anyway
not real sure why any of your there
while we allow any of you to hang out
then around pop your gums but this is a
chance for you to actually reach over
and stupid Education Department that's
kind of funny when you just say that in
a sentence stupid
Education Department you know that's
kind of funny oxymoronic part of this is
scary so here's the rule don't trust
federal government it sounds like a
conspiracy theory doesn't it and don't
get in a line that takes you 10 years to
pay off your student loan debt that was
dumb to start with just get yourself out
of debt in like two years
in 12 months like we hear all the time
on here with the debt free screams this
is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]